paul in ghostbusters there are lots of
very impressive special effects and
visual effects but you yourself using a
camera phone
you can create a visual effect
i can yes where it appears that people
are seeing something they're not that's
right okay can you demonstrate it
sure good
[Applause]
um can i just say you are all going to
be trying this
yeah this is uh
okay i can i tried
okay what do i need to do just sit there
okay this should be fine
all right
i think we can
do you know what he's doing yes i do
you will in a miracle
it should be synced to uh yeah i think
it's sync now so here's the picture that
you just took
so
[Applause]
it does look like a
i'm bum
much really confused
what what happened
oh yes do miriam there we go are you
doing it with your fingers
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what is that
it does look like a bottom yes
i happen to have really sausage looking
fingers
that make a really nice tush and you can
frame you
you can frame it frame the camera so it
looks like you're just being just i just
got to know how you discovered this
unique i know that's what i wanted
and actually
there's an even more sophisticated
version
yeah okay
there's there's you can do i mean
well let's see if i can
i don't know if it's if sophisticated is
the right word but
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
very good
[Music]
you